- [Sal] We are now going
to go further in our study
of the evolution of the empires in Asia.
And in this video, we're
going to focus on what happens
in North India, Persia, the Middle East,
and the Anatolian peninsula,
what we would consider modern-day Turkey.
So right here is roughly
what Asia looked like
around the year 1300.
As you might remember
from previous videos,
as we entered into the 13th century,
you have Genghis Khan or Genghis
Khan take over much of Asia
from Mongolia.
But by the time you get to
1300, the empire has fragmented
into these various khanates.
The Yuan Dynasty in China,
Chagatai Khanate in Central Asia,
the Golden Horde in Northwest Asia,
and the Ilkhanate in
Persia and the Middle East.
Now, two things to keep note
of as we look at this map
that are relevant to this video
is notice this tiny little
kingdom right over here.
This is one of the many
fragmented kingdoms that result
after the Sultanate of Rum collapses
in the middle of the 13th century.
This kingdom in particular
is founded by someone
by the name of Osman, or the
Arabic version of the name
would be Uthman or Othman.
And so this is the nascent
Ottoman empire forming
right over here.
And over here you have
the Delhi Sultanate,
which was the first
significant Muslim empire
over in North India.
And notably, they were
one of the few empires
that were able to fend off the Mongols.
But now let's fast
forward roughly 100 years.
Now a few things have changed.
The Ming Dynasty has taken
over the Yuan Dynasty
in the middle of the 14th century.
The Mongols in the east are now relegated
to the Northern Yuan Dynasty,
but there still is the Chagatai Khanate
and the Golden Horde.
But much of their territory,
including the Ilkhanate,
has now been taken over by Timur,
who we talk about in previous videos.
And Timur famously sacked Delhi
and really brought the
Delhi Sultanate to its knees
and as we will see, it will only last
for roughly another 100 years.
Now, you might also notice
that the Ottoman empire,
founded by Osman or Othman
is continuing to grow
and continuing to conquer.
Now one thing to keep in mind.
In previous videos, we talk
about the invention of gunpowder
in Tang China and the early Song dynasty,
which was about four to five hundred years
before the period that we're
talking about right now.
But as we get into this period,
we are now starting to see
the use of gunpowder for guns
and in particular artillery.
And when I say artillery, think cannons.
So let's fast forward another 200 years
to see how the empires
of Asia have evolved.
So now we see several things.
The Ming Dynasty is still
in control of much of China.
The Northern Yuan are still in Mongolia.
You have a Kazakh Khanate,
descendant from the Mongols.
By the late 16th and early 17th century
the Ottoman Empire has now
expanded significantly,
encompassing much of the Middle East.
In Persia, you see that
the Timurid Empire fell
within a few decades
after the death of Timur.
And as we enter into the 16th century,
you have the Safavid Dynasty take over.
And then also in the 16th
century, almost coincident
with the founding of the
Safavid Dynasty in Persia,
you have Timur's grandson's
great-grandson, Babur,
who's born in current-day
Uzbekistan, is able to defeat
the Delhi Sultanate and
establish the Mughal Empire.
And Mughal is just the
Persian word for Mongol
and Babur is a direct descendant of Timur
on his father's side and of Genghis Khan
on his mother's side.
Now, many historians often group
these three empires or dynasties together
because they do share some commonalities.
And so let's think about
each of them individually
and think about where they are similar
and where they are different.
Not a lot is known about Osman
who founds that first kingdom
in the Anatolian peninsula.
It's a Sunni Islamic empire.
In fact, the leader is
eventually named a caliph.
The ruling class of
this empire is Turkish.
Now, one of their
distinguishing characteristics
is what's known as the Devshirme system
in which the Sultan, the Emperor,
would have a personal army
of what could be called
slaves, these Janissaries.
These Janissaries were
actually Christian boys
taken at a young age
and then indoctrinated
into the Janissary system.
The reason why I said you
can kind of call them slaves
is that although they were
forced to become Janissaries
and taken from their families,
they were given many
privileges and over time,
many of these Janissaries
became some of the most
notable figures in the Ottoman Empire,
some of them even
becoming the Grand Vizier,
effectively ruling over the empire.
Now, the Ottomans are also known
for one of the earliest
empires to very successfully
to use gunpowder in battle.
The Safavids, as you can see
here, were really founded
in the very early 16th
century, officially 1501,
by their founder Shah Ismail,
sometimes known as Ismail I.
And he is the heir to a
religious dynasty, the Safavias.
It is a Muslim dynasty,
like the Ottoman Empire,
but unlike the Ottoman Empire,
it is based on Twelver Shia Islam.
Twelver Shia is the major
group of Shias today
and it is based on the belief of 12 imams
following Mohammed starting with Ali
and we have videos on
the Sunni-Shia split.
Now, even though Ismail spoke Turkish
and was raised in a Turkic society,
this dynasty brought
back much of the culture
of Ancient Persia.
In fact, it's viewed as the first dynasty
since the Sassanids that
actually had native Persian rule
and brought back that Persian culture,
part of which is using the word Shah.
You remember Cyrus the
Great, the Shahanshah,
the King of Kings.
Now they had what is known as
Ghulams, which is very similar
to the idea of a Janissary.
These are slave soldiers
which are taken as captives
but then are raised to
be an elite military unit
and eventually often
have significant wealth
and significant power.
Now you might be wondering,
why did any of these empires
and these aren't the only
ones, you have the Mamluks
and other Muslim empires.
Why would people create these
elite soldiers out of slaves
and give them that much power?
Well, the answer is, they
were the safest people
to give power to.
Remember, these empires
are ruling over many tribes
and many groups and many kingdoms
that are constantly vying for power,
trying to establish their own dynasties.
And if you allowed people
from those various tribes
to protect you as Emperor,
well, there might be a good shot
that one of them might want to kill you
and establish their own dynasty.
But from a young age, if
you could indoctrinate
these young boys as
Ghulams, or as Janissaries,
well, they might be more loyal to you.
And indeed, it did provide an
unusual amount of stability.
As I mentioned, the Mughal
Empire was able to be founded
by Babur, who was Timur's
great-grandson's grandson
and he, too, was born in a
Turco-Mongolian tradition.
As he's able to famously
defeat the Delhi Sultanate
which had already been
significantly weakened,
one, on its own, but then by
Timur over 100 years before,
he famously comes to power
with the aid of gunpowder,
being able to defeat
a significantly larger
Delhi Sultanate army.
The Mughals practiced Sunni Islam
but they ruled over a
large Hindu majority,
and so the first several Mughal rulers
were actually quite tolerant.
Perhaps the most tolerant was Akbar,
often known as Akbar the Great,
who we'll do other videos on,
who actually tried to create a religion
which was a merger
between Islam and Hinduism
and Jainism and Christianity.
But then they become less tolerant
under Shah Jahan and Aurangzeb.
Shah Jahan famous for building
the Taj Mahal for his wife,
but what's often not
noted is he was building
this fairly grand mausoleum at a time
when there was a famine in India
and he was also known as
being fairly intolerant
and persecuted many Hindus and Sikhs
and his son, Aurangzeb,
continued to do so.
Now, some historians will
refer to these three empires
as the Gunpowder Empires.
If someone says Gunpowder Empires,
they're referring to these three.
The reason why they're
called that is this view
that these major centralized
empires were able to form
only with the power of gunpowder.
The Ottomans, famous for
early use of artillery.
The Mughals, Babur in particular,
came to power with gunpowder.
But today, historians are
somewhat skeptical of grouping
just these three empires
as Gunpowder Empires.
You had many other large
centralized empires form
before the use of gunpowder.
So that whole thesis is
not as popular today.